[Music]
every year about a thousand new words
are added to the oxford english
dictionary where do they come from
and how do they make it into our
everyday lives with over a hundred
seventy thousand words currently in use
in the English language
it might seem we already have plenty yet
as our world changes new ideas and
inventions spring forth and science
progresses our existing words leave gaps
in what we want to express and we fill
those gaps in several ingenious
practical and occasionally peculiar ways
one way is to absorb a word from another
language English has borrowed so many
words over its history that nearly half
of its vocabulary comes directly from
other languages sometimes this is simply
because the thing the word describes was
borrowed itself Rome and France brought
legal and religious concepts like altar
and jury to medieval England while trade
brought crops and cuisine like Arabic
coffee Italian spaghetti and Indian
curry but sometimes another language has
just the right word for a complex idea
or emotion like naivete machismo or
schadenfreude scientists also use
classical languages to name new concepts
cloned for example was derived from the
ancient Greek word for twig to describe
creating a new plant from a piece of the
old
and today the process works both ways
with English lending words like software
two languages all over the world
another popular way to fill a vocabulary
gap is by combining existing words that
each convey part of the new concept this
can be done by combining two whole words
into a compound word like airport or
starfish or by clipping and blending
parts of words together like spork
brunch or Internet and unlike borrowings
from other languages these can often be
understood the first time you hear them
and sometimes a new word isn't new at
all obsolete words gain new life by
adopting new meanings Villain originally
meant a peasant farmer but in a twist of
aristocratic snobbery came to mean
someone not bound by the Knightly code
of chivalry and therefore a bad person a
geek went from being a carnival
performer to any strange person to a
specific type of awkward genius and
other times words come to mean their
opposite through irony metaphor or
misuse like when sick or wicked are used
to describe something literally amazing
but if words can be formed in all these
ways why do some become mainstream while
others fall out of use or never catch on
in the first place
sometimes the answer is simple as when
scientists or companies give an official
name to a new discovery or technology
and some countries have language
academies to make the decisions but for
the most part official sources like
dictionaries only document current usage
new words don't originate from above but
from ordinary people spreading words
that hit the right combination of the
useful and catchy take the word meme
coined in the 1970s by socio biologist
Richard Dawkins from the ancient Greek
for imitation he used it to describe how
ideas and symbols propagate through a
culture like genes through a population
with the advent of the internet the
process became directly observable in
how jokes and images were popularized at
lightning speed and soon the word came
to refer to a certain kind of image so
meme not only describes how words become
part of language the word is a mean
itself and there's a word for this
phenomenon of words that describe
themselves autological
not all new words are created equal some
stick around for millennia some adapt to
changing times and others die off some
relay information some interpret it but
the way these words are created and the
journey they take to become part of our
speech tells us a lot about our world
and how we communicate within it on the
ted-ed website we have a video series
called mysteries of vernacular that's
dedicated to exploring the origins of
odd and interesting words there are 26
videos in all one for each letter in the
English alphabet and one of the videos
in the series investigates the cryptic
conception of the word clue
do you already know this words origin
story if not here's a quick visual hint
any guesses here's the hint again click
here or below for the full answer and if
you enjoy the experience please share
the series with the logo files in your
life